pese a los más de 200 tiroteos en cinco
meses del 2022 en eeuu la asociación
nacional del rifle se prepara para su
reunión anual en texas este viernes una
cita que se espera tenga una amplia
posición en las calles el alcalde
demócrata de houston sede del encuentro
aseguró que la ciudad recibirá la
convención pese a la oposición a las
críticas de la fifa sé que mucha gente
que piensa que hay demasiadas armas por
aquí estoy de acuerdo con usted también
hay personas que piensan que se debería
prohibir la venta de armas siempre en
eso también estoy de acuerdo y
sin embargo ni el malestar de los
ciudadanos ni la reciente masacre en
balde fueron suficientes para detener el
evento al que se espera asistan más de
55 mil personas y donde se escucharán
los discursos del ex presidente don al
chrome y de los legisladores
republicanos en texas entre otros la que
se negó a asistir fue la compañía daniel
defense fabricante del arma utilizada en
el tiroteo de la escuela primaria rock
el martes pero como siga adelante un
evento de tal magnitud en un país donde
las masacres con armas de asalto no se
detienen analistas resaltan la presión
que ejerce la asociación sobre la
ejerce un poder muy importante
particularmente en el congreso y
específicamente en el senado a nivel
federal y tiene mucho control en las
legislaturas estatales particularmente
en estados como texas o tennessee donde
hay muchas personas que portan y tienen
tienen armas la asociación nacional del
rifle da muchas donaciones a campañas y
aquellos
políticos que no sigan las pautas de la
asociación nacional del rifle y de la
industria simplemente apoyan a un
candidato de oposición entonces es
mediante este donaciones y apoyo en
campañas que ejercen un control
importante a favor de las ganancias de
la industria y no a favor de la
seguridad de los ciudadanos en un
escenario convulso para los
estadounidenses el congreso de eeuu
sigue sin ponerse de acuerdo en una ley
que limite significativamente la
tenencia de armas que está protegida en
la segunda enmienda de la constitución